-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy and Tony Award-winning,
Grammy-nominated actor you know
from his work in iconic films
such as "When Harry Met Sally,"
"City Slickers"
and "Analyze This."
He stars in
"Mr. Saturday Night,"
which is playing at the
Nederlander Theatre on Broadway.
It is currently nominated for
five Tony Awards,
including Best Leading Actor
in a Musical
and Best Book of a Musical.
Please welcome to the show
the legendary Billy Crystal,
everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm wonderful. Congratulations.
This is -- Not only
are you making
your musical comedy debut --
-At 74.
-Yeah.
-A little bit later than most.
-Yeah. Yeah, I know.
It's been thrilling.
-And you also -- five nominees,
including Lead Actor,
Best Musical, and Best Book,
which is a big deal too
because obviously that is,
you know, that's the comedy.
That's the the backbone
of the show.
-We did this movie in 1991
with Lowell Ganz
and Babaloo Mandel.
And then this sort of came up,
and we kept working on it
and working on it.
We wrote it together
and here we are.
It's been a great hit,
and we love doing it
and to do it with them --
You know, when we wrote
the movie, we were 41.
-Yeah.
-We're not anymore.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-So to get a nomination for
the three of us
for the Best Book of a Musical
is thrilling for us.
-And the other, of course,
fascinating thing is
when you made this movie
in 1991, you were telling
the whole life of Buddy Young
Jr., who is this comedian.
And you had to age up
a great deal in the film.
-Yeah, plus I directed it, so I
was in six hours of makeup a day
for 54 of the 72-day shoot,
you know, to be 75 years old.
Now I just show up.
-Yeah.
-Which is, like,
it's very thrilling.
They actually have to make me
look younger sometimes.
No, it's a great -- it's a great
character to play,
you know,
because we love comedians.
And to do it live is amazing
because he's abrasive sometimes.
He's always hilarious.
He's confused.
He's his worst enemy.
And to get that from the
audience instantly is thrilling.
And also to have David Paymer,
who played my brother
in the film,
plays my brother Stan
in the show.
He was nominated for an Oscar
for the film,
for Best Supporting Actor.
So we're like a pair of
old shoes together,
and I mean "old" shoes.
-Yeah.
Well, it is -- I mean,
it's really sweet
that it's not just the writing
team -- Ganz and Mandel.
It's also David Paymer.
It's also yourself.
Are there times, again, being
a debutante at 74 onstage,
do you ever feel your age
when you're onstage?
-No. Today I do.
-Okay.
-Well, Broadway schedules
are insane.
-Insane.
-This is your one day off,
we should note.
-Yeah, so from Friday to Sunday,
we do four shows in 36 hours.
-Yeah.
-And it's a lot.
The audiences have been
phenomenal.
I can't tell you, at this point
in my life and my career,
to feel so excited about doing
something every night?
-Yeah.
-It's a really cool thing.
-Can you clock right away
what kind of audience
you have on any given night?
Have you been doing the show
long enough to see
the different kinds,
or have they been
pretty consistent?
-They've been phenomenal.
But there are some nights,
you know, ugh.
Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
Ugh, ugh.
Because when it's work,
it's not fun.
-Right.
-When it's fun, it's great fun.
-And then I would imagine,
especially not only being
in a comedy but being in
a comedy that you created
the character, you worked on the
script, I imagine you can let it
breathe in a way on the nights
where it's really working.
The audience can probably
elevate it beyond
what it even is on the page.
-Yeah, that's a good point
because we have a lot of fun.
And when it cooks, it takes off.
And I can't imagine a show
on Broadway being this funny
consistently like this.
It's great.
-Obviously, you have a movie
that you work on a great deal.
It has a movie premiere where
you're sitting in the audience.
-Right.
-Broadway shows have a premiere.
It's a whole different thing
because you also have to work
that night.
It's not just sit and watch.
-Yeah.
-Do you prefer one or the other?
-Oh, I prefer the Broadway
thing.
-Yeah.
-Because you got to bring it.
-With a movie premiere, like --
If you're an actor, you did it
maybe the year before.
Maybe six months before.
If you directed it,
maybe you just finished it
a couple of months before.
You know, and then you just
watch it.
Then you go, "I wish I could
change it, but I can't."
You have to bring at Broadway.
And there's a lot of big people
in the audience,
and word goes out fast
if it didn't go well.
It's like,
"You know, it's not that good."
[ Laughter ]
And it hits the streets
really quick.
We had a phenomenal
opening night.
-This is really cool because,
of course, I --
When I first became aware of
you, it was on "SNL,"
so I knew you first and foremost
as a live performer,
but you had grandkids
who came to your show
who never had seen you
perform live.
-Right. Yeah, the girls are 18
and 16, the boys are 12 and 9.
And they came in from L.A.
They knew me mostly in
the beginning as Mike Wazowski.
You know, from --
[ Laughter ]
So they would call the house,
I'd go "Hello?"
"Oh, is Mike there?"
"Yeah. Hold on, I'll get him."
[ as Mike Wazowski ]
"Oh, hi, how is everybody?
Everyone okay?"
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Yeah.
-It's interesting to me
because --
I'm glad to hear that because
obviously, I have --
A great many of my friends
have done voiceover work,
and they say their kids hate it
when they do the voices
of the characters
they play in movies.
Maybe it's better if it skips
a generation
and it's a grandparent.
-Maybe. Maybe.
Yeah, but then they hit on
"Princess Bride"
because those are the things
I could show them.
-Sure.
-I couldn't explain to the girls
why Meg is screaming in
the deli when they're young.
"Oh, no, the pastrami was spicy.
"Yes, yes! I don't like this!
Yes, I don't like this!"
[ Laughter ]
-For their wedding day,
you can tell them.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, no, it's been -- So it was
thrilling to have them there
with my daughters.
-You also had -- Talk about some
big names in the audience.
You had Marty and Steve.
-Yeah.
-It must be nice.
I mean, not just --
[ Applause ]
Not just comedians you respect,
but guys, you know, who are of
your generation, when they come
and see that like that.
-Yeah, they were great.
And Tina Fey was there,
and a lot of other amazing
people who I so respect.
And to have them come to, you
know, see the show was great.
-And I didn't realize Buddy was
originated --
I knew him first from the film.
-Right.
-But he was a character
you started doing
at "SNL" back in the day.
-Yeah, I actually did it before
on a special called
"A Comic's Line" on HBO.
And he was only
like for 30 seconds,
a little insult-comic sketch
that we did.
And then I brought him here,
right down the block.
-Yeah.
-He was an insult comic
and we did him on the news desk.
So I was like
a restaurant critic.
And I would put down these
restaurants like Don Rickles
with a bad toupee and so forth.
And then one night,
our great producer --
because Lorne was not there
the year that I did the show --
Dick Ebersol.
-Yeah.
-Who was at the show yesterday.
It was so great to see him
again.
And we talked about it.
Chris Guest was the anchor
on "Update."
And so Dick came to me and said,
"Johnny Cash and June are
in the audience with Waylon
Jennings and Christopher Reeve.
Do you want me to put them
near the news desk
in case you want to leave
the desk and go Rickle them?"
You know? So I said, "Great."
So I was doing
my restaurant review,
and it was a bad restaurant.
It was funny stuff
and funny stuff.
And I just grabbed the hand mike
and went after them
in the audience, and just --
we just improvised.
It was just great.
It was really funny.
-That's fantastic, and so unlike
the "SNL" I knew.
And I have more questions about
that improv style.
We'll be right back with more
from Billy Crystal.